bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
stream salut Kevin comment tu vas ça va
très bien salut tout salut tout le monde
on est reparti sous vous avez un petit
moment qu'on avait pas commenté tous les
deux ça me fait bien bien plaisir de te
retrouver de vous retrouver ça va être
ça va être un événement assez sympa yes
c'est clair ça fait longtemps qu'on
s'est pas vu Kevin du coup je suis très
très content de te retrouver encore
aujourd'hui alors on se match très
intéressant et on va voir entre les
entre les bons le bon truc je vais vous
changer ça avec les MGD 1 2 2 enfin
l'équipe indien d'irégasi contre du coup
les Norway gnoms de de
il y a du monde et Eliana etc donc à
partir de commencer on va de
suite vers les parties vous avez déjà
ici les joueurs qui sont installés tout
ça je vais vous changer j'ai oublié de
le faire je suis désolé le score chips
avec
du coup les
premiers à Paris non
qui s'est faite malmener et ce qu'on
disait en fait hier tu as un monstre
dedans mais si Carlson il assume pas son
rôle favori en fait et ben c'est c'est
très difficile parce que si tu veux oui
mais il est quand même ramené en plus à
200700 donc finalement
oui mais le problème en fait c'est
qu'ils mettent une féminine en 2002 et
elle fait elle fait 0 et en fait tout le
temps et du coup tu ferais faut arriver
à 8 et demi pour gagner et tu commences
avec 0 104 et devant ces personnes 404
ça s'équilibre donc en fait c'est pas
vraiment un avantage tu vois
complètement expliqué hier et moi je
pense que c'est bien d'avoir une
féminine genre là c'était qui là
l'équipe indienne
je te disais en aparté que je voyais
bien les Indiens parce que
la féminine si elle venait à faire zéro
c'est un gros handicap et Arica au-delà
alors il faudrait qu'elle marque son
point déjà contre l'autre féminine en
face mais la dernière fois que j'ai
commencé à Rica et là aussi gagner
contre un 2006 du coup elle est hyper
dangereuse elle se bat énormément elle
est grand maître mixtes elle joue tout
simplement mieux que nous un stouf et du
coup c'est elle est vraiment elle est
vraiment très forte harika
elle peut elle peut très bien sur une
partie
battre un ohwell ou un jour comme ça
bien sûr alors que la fille à 2002
si elle fait pas 0 c'est un exploit
complètement donc en fait c'est vrai que
voilà après au niveau de la de la
gestion c'est clair que quand tu prends
une fille à 2002 et ben tu peux mettre
plus de joueurs forts devant mais pas
tant que ça
parce que du coup on a dit que la
féminine est quand même remontée enfin à
23,50
enfin plutôt descendu entre 50 c'est à
dire que si tu as une grand maître à
2500 vélos et ben la remonter à 23,50 ce
qui veut dire que là dans cet équipe là
tu mets une fille à 23 à 50 elle peut
aussi faire zéro vu tout le monde qui a
devant tu vois alors que là par contre
la fille elle a 25 quoi pour 100 points
de différence chez les filles en fait tu
lui prends 300 points quoi enfin je sais
pas si vous comprenez ce que je veux
dire mais
ah non mais si en fait
d'ailleurs ouais à ce niveau là
c'est pas c'est moyennement juste cette
histoire de ça devrait être normalement
bah ton hello qui qui s'affiche je
t'aurais pas y avoir de carottes par
rapport à ça mais je pense que ils
veulent pas ils veulent favoriser les
super joueurs parce que ils veulent
briser qu'il y a du beau monde dans
cette compétition mais aussi les super
filles aussi parce que
s'ils mettent s'ils font la même chose
chez les filles je pense que ils veulent
aussi que niveau quoi complètement mais
ouais mais au final du coup ben
là l'équipe des des Norway ben elle est
un peu handicapée par la fille bon après
on va voir ce qu'elle fait hein là on
dit ça mais aussi bien elle va raser
tout le monde mais c'est vrai que
normalement son papier là l'équipe elle
part déjà
par favorite quoi complètement c'est
juste ça
alors attends je me continue juste à
régler les trucs là
[Musique]
bienvenue à tous
et d'Europe ça se passe bien pour les
Français effectivement donc bon et là
sur cette sur ce premier match donc on
voilà on a les matchs les plus
déséquilibrés vous voyez
la jeune chassis joue contrario du coup
qui est mon parallèle de club à plus de
2700 hello c'était notre échiquier
numéro 1 là en Division 1 c'est-à-dire
au Top 16 et il avait bien assumé son
rang et donc il est au plus proposé à
une joueuse à 2002 un peu plus qui a
décidé d'agresser avec les Blancs je
pense que c'est plutôt une bonne
stratégie pour elle de jouer des parties
d'attaque et d'essayer de marquer le
point entier en attaquant le roi adverse
maintenant on voit qu'elle a plutôt
l'attaque a été plutôt contrôlée
et ça serait très étonnant que à
rioneergasi
issu combat très clairement
après on sait jamais ça va être sur une
petite une
erreur un peu vite arriver tu sais que
on a vu ben par exemple on a vu Nakamura
perdre contre Joséphine Henneman
donc bon ben une surprise est vite
arrivé il faut faire attention quand
même pas sous-estimer je pense pas que
ce soit le genre d'yazies mais les 2400
déjà ça fait quand même une grosse
Heyman je dis pas de bêtises c'est à peu
près
400 2350
[Musique]
c'est la jeune la jeune qui était
entraînée par en fait il me semble-t-il
je ne peux pas te dire j'avance à rien
je l'avais vu elle était déjà elle était
déjà très forte ok
[Musique]
mais en tout cas oui elle était un
profil intéressant et je la voyais déjà
bien plus forte que cela en tout cas
j'aime bien le panache stouf
est-ce que tu la converti parce que là
je te retrouve bien dans cette petite
attaque que
si nous met j'espère que ça plaît direct
bah écoute à l'époque j'étais un peu un
fou furieux j'aimais bien les positions
comme ça attaquer un petit peu j'ai
envie de dire un peu à l'arrache quoi
parce que là tu as pas ok tu as pas fini
de t'en sortir de pièces maintenant bah
écoute mon jeu un peu mûri
cette position ben je n'aime pas du tout
ce que le fait que les blancs on est
d'accord je trouve que c'est précipité
le roi d'un corps ensemble après bon
j'ai cinq peut arriver mais je
trouve que elle vend clairement et
charmant sa peau mais
ouais c'est un peu tout match en doute
parce que
en fait à un niveau donc à son niveau
qui est 2200 bah oui c'est intéressant
parce qu'en fait c'est amateur etc et
puis il peut passer plein de choses mais
là contre yazi bon il va juste voir
prendre les trous et
voilà quoi j'aime bien je trouve mais je
sais pas si il marche mais F5 je regarde
est-ce que tu peux pas contracter des
fois l'ordinateur fait des choses comme
ça maintenant
on le voit on se fait attaquer d'un côté
en fait on réagit et F5 c'est chaud j'ai
pas trouvé la réfute
j'aime bien
bon j'ai le plaisir voilà
du coup
ça avait l'air pas mal ça ouvrait tout
vous voyez que la bon les cartes
blanches sont assez ouvertes quand même
mais la Tour Blanche enfin la tendance
aussi attaque le roi qui n'a pas ok
c'est intéressant salut robinside et
c'est le ciel bleu salut à tous
ça fait plaisir
bienvenue à tous en tout cas sur le
stream et puis du coup donc voilà ce
match assez intéressant moi je vous
mettrais quand même une pièce ou un
petit SAB si je peux parler comme ça sur
les Indiens
complètement mais tu sais pas parier
qu'on ne partenaires de club puisque tu
la voyais arriver
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé de danser une
petite ah tu m'as vendu tu m'as rendu un
moment une super équipe des nord-ouest
qui ont une super équipe il est vrai
mais ils ont une féminine bien plus
faible ok en moyenne élo les trois gars
sont légèrement au dessus mais on sait
que les joueurs indiens sont sont rompus
à ce type de match et du coup on les
sent pas faible même le mettre à 2500 il
va être il va être dangereux très
clairement
et ben attends même vous mettre les noms
si vous voulez
des joueurs et après on ira peut-être
faire un petit tour de tous les
échiquiers pour voir un petit peu vous
savez qu'au début on souffle là il est
en train de tout mettre pour que ça soit
justement en termes d'expérience le plus
sympa pour tout le monde et qu'on puisse
se tourner
yes du coup donc vous pouvez voir la
partie 2 et j'ai une petite question au
niveau des temps des parties
ouais ça je sais bien mais sur la scène
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont volé
effectivement tu as bien raison
tu as bien raison
tu sais bien comment ça se passe
maintenant dès que je n'oste pas alors
là je peux te dire que je fais toutes
les remarques possibles et imaginables
particulièrement pour Laurent qui comme
tu le sais à beaucoup de mal avec Obs
donc je suis obligé à chaque fois
d'intervenir voilà j'avais pas en fait
c'est à chaque fois vu que j'étais
captures d'écran sur chaque en fait
chaque temps c'est capture d'écran et du
coup c'est vrai que j'avais pas
rafraîchi les pages mais tu viens de me
dire j'avais pas vu cette cadence en 10
+ 2 en plus c'est assez sympa quand ça
devient speed donc
[Musique]
alors est-ce qu'on passe du coup la
partie 2 ouais parce que là bon c'est en
train de mal se passer comment ça va
mettre cette pièce de manière très
bizarre oh c'est beaucoup plus plat ici
on te fait un petit travail sur la case
D5 c'est ça ressemble à une structure
d'espagnol il suffit de
voir de voir la position des pions pour
ce douter de snap avec pas grand chose
sans doute mais une casse des 5 pour les
blancs la colonne A pour les Noirs c'est
très équilibré un tout
ouais et c'est aussi une partie qui est
qui est assez chose voyez on a on a les
noms des joueurs qui apparaît tabac
contre tabac Tabe contre pranave alors
tabac tabac c'est un genre qui a joué
pour mon équipe à Cannes échec lors du
Top 12
qu'un joueur hyper impressionnant
iranien plus de 26 50 et epranave c'est
un joueur que j'ai enfin un indien très
très sympathique qui est jeune grand
maître et les grands il a maintenant 15
ans je crois et les grands maîtres
depuis depuis quelques mois et donc 25
50 15 16 ans je sais pas combien entre
15 et 16
et je l'ai joué au droit de Créon en
France il avait il avait 11 ans et 2002
et j'avais fait nul
j'espère que tu l'aies collé tu sais
c'est vraiment des jeunes mais ils sont
pas faciles à jouer oui non mais en fait
à l'époque était un peu jeune un peu
naïf et c'était une destinienne mais
très positionnelle où j'avais réussi à
bien bien torturer jusqu'au moment où je
suis gagnant et tactiquement bah il me
pose des problèmes c'était pas si simple
et derrière et ben je suis gagnant mais
je répète une fois deux fois et puis
après je fais un truc et je reviens et
je vais j'ai fait nul sans faire exprès
j'étais beaucoup mieux j'avais gagné
quoi et
souvenir une anecdote du coup est-ce que
ça annule tout
la nul contre lui est-ce que ça la
rembourse le fait que tu es une petite
anecdote du coup grâce à ça une bonne
anecdote parce que la petite nul tu veux
pas la faire c'est quand même enfin
c'est quand même rageant quoi bah oui
non bah il est évident que vous voulez
gagner quoi mais j'ai pas fait exprès
bon maintenant il est grand maître donc
bon ben je suis ok j'ai vu le contenu tu
vois on a
50 % voilà avec les noirs que j'ai fait
nul sans même vouloir voilà bon
j'avoue j'ai pas fait exprès et quand on
a fait trois fois la même position il
arrête l'arbitre qui me dit drôle et moi
je dis
et on a vu que ça avait trois fois il
était tout content et bah moi non
arnaque et on va dire enfin ce midi tout
seul là
j'ai 5 alors c'est volontaire on peut
faire que j'ai 5 F4 ou c'est ou c'est
tout match
en tout cas c'est clairement le truc
qu'on veut faire
ok j'ai envie de voir payer pour voir ce
que j'ai le droit de faire F4
mais bon ça semble être quand même le
bon fais gaffe à tourin aussi
alors pourquoi il a fait H5 il avait
peur que les Blancs le fasse eux-mêmes
non
avec avec le problème ici sur G5 j'ai la
case F5 pour un cavalier
donc c'est ouais il a pas très figé on
attaque sur les ailes et le pion h on
peut l'envoyer facilement un souffle
c'est un des thèmes clés vous voyez le
pion h c'est le moins affaiblissant
préparer F4 comme tu le disais
et sur F4 qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur F4 je
sais pas trop je trouve qu'on est un peu
moins bien avec les Noirs après
f4i a gagné sa partie d'ailleurs contre
Chelsea on a même pas vu la fin
ça a été vite hein on va l'avoir si tu
veux rapidement
c'est le raisin juste rapidement alors
on s'arrêtait à fou B7 tours géant ah
oui alors envoyer la sauce
de manière bizarre faut acheter rusé
[Musique]
et sacrifier avec un mat le prochain
ouais grosse grosse partie hein gagner
assez facilement de la part de tabac de
la part de grigasi pas trop de suspense
donc on avait bien lu les intentions de
pranave mais tabac Tabe il va défendre
tranquillement il est pas foutu non plus
puisque on peut pas jouer F5 facilement
ce que je pourrais
manger là
ou de la dame on a le droit parce qu'il
y a quand même le pion G3
il va préparer tranquillement son
attaque et voir si un jour sur le long
terme
parce que souvent
tous les joueurs amateurs s'ouvre
majoritairement préfère attaquer et ne
savent pas trop défendre alors que plus
on monte en niveau plus les joueurs
acceptent de défendre certaines
positions et là ce qui propose c'est
solide maintenant il a réussi à régler
les problèmes
il a viré le cavalier G5 poison avec
cette petite manœuvre toute simple fois
6 rois G7 F6 très très bien joué ça n'a
l'air de rien comme ça mais ce genre de
en fait exactement contrôle tout quoi
toutes les cases et d'ailleurs c'est
même moi que la colonne A c'est aussi
important de dire
et parce que oui si je préfère tout à 7
ce sera quand même différent mais là du
coup les noirs sont assez actifs et
c'est vrai que leur pion comprend quand
même pas mal de cases j'interdis
beaucoup les blancs d'arriver là faut
voir s'il y a pas moins de casser tout
ça alors
coulisser la dame moi de mon côté dame
c'est dedans j'ai deux
ou dames et devient défendre le cavalier
en gendarma F2 pour faire F5 enfin
j'aimerais bien faire quelque chose soit
j'écarte soit F5
mais c'est quand même plus plaisant un
jeu pour les blancs ça c'est clair mais
les noirs sont en Russie à base de
défendre dans cette
position
la variable temps évidemment est-ce
qu'on peut faire un petit tour de des
stades souffre histoire en l'ultra
zaynote parce que ça va pas tarder là
vous avez David hawel avec les Blancs
contre
moi
contre Arica
qui est la numéro 1
indienne et mondial elle doit être top 3
2500 et quelques 3 4 5 je dis rien
un peu
je suis en train de le faire déjà
et elle est 3e elle a 25,76
[Musique]
il faut quasiment être 26 pour pour être
dans le top 3 et après ça se ça se
vraiment ça descend assez vite
[Musique]
[Rires]
t'inquiète t'inquiète on est bon
[Musique]
à deux et un seul titre c'est bon et
puis comme je t'ai dit j'en avais
beaucoup des normes de mètres
avant de passer
le titre deux fois dont une fois un
point et l'autre et ça ça va être fait
mal quand même
moi j'ai raté le titre sur une partie
j'ai eu deux fois l'occasion de moi j'ai
raté le titre sur un coup sauf à
l'époque
je le vois je le dis bah je vais
attendre la fin du zinnote et je vais le
jouer au suivant sauf qu'il m'a empêché
de le faire c'était chrono ça le fort
malheureusement décédé aujourd'hui
et du coup
bah du coup il m'empêchait de le faire
je regarde mon hello le soir en rentrant
la chambre 23,96 donc en gagnant puisque
j'avais 23,65 et jouer à 25 23 tu vois
je connais même les lots bah c'était bon
et du coup vexe
ok c'est une position assez cool pour
les blancs donc il y a ce pion arrière
en
en C3 mais souvent on a des possibilités
alors je sais pas tu vas me dire si
c'est possible Kevin est-ce que un coût
du style bon elle joue pas trop alors
peut-être passer le fou à me faire un
truc comme ça et fermer la porte
pourquoi pas moi je pensais en fait un
jeu B4 et placer le cavalier en deux et
puis placer le cavalier
il y avait le plan cavalier 8 dci ça
alors il y a pas de damaschette mais en
tout cas il faut regarder les timings de
prise de casse dans ce cas là et elle
s'est peut-être dit
tout dépend comme mon interprète le coup
B4 des des noirs sans doute pas possible
à cause de simplement de ses promesses
et puis on pas assez fou des deux B4
donc du coup si elle est maître
maîtresse de l'attention elle est un peu
de temps pour préparer son bécasse et
donc dans ce cas là
c'est pas trop je pense non mais en fait
finalement
celle qui décide donc autant préparer à
kfc1
ce serait marrant qu'elle est ripée
qu'elle voulait jouer en fait
mais cavalier séance ça va commencer à
devenir vraiment embêtant parce que dame
1 vous voyez le petit passage il faut
passer par des trois je pense tout comme
ça j'ai le temps de pas dire si je bouge
le pion B3 ok à faire au dernier moment
B4 parce que
B4 prise et
Tours C2
c'est un joueur que moi j'ai beaucoup
j'ai beaucoup joué contre lui sur
Internet
et c'est un joueur qui qui est très très
souvent en tant que note
et même avec très peu de temps la pendu
il m'a il est hyper fort et moi je le
joue tout le temps il avait toujours 30
secondes contre une minute trente comme
ça et à chaque fois une bataille en tout
cas ça c'est ça
il a utilisé un plan pour liquider la
colonne A et maintenant on a une couette
[Musique]
alors que tout à l'heure j'aime bien en
fait sur le long terme ça fait baisse la
son tu vois peut-être un H4 et tu vois
des petits
guilis un peu troués donc ça peut être
véritablement très dangereux
pour essayer peut-être un jour de faire
C4 si tu boules de dames on est en train
de balbutier un petit peu
[Musique]
est-ce que tu vois rapidement ce qui se
passe sur mon mon sur mon petit Paris
mon petit Paris mon petit Paris je
t'avais dit en off que je pensais que le
joueur indien allait peut-être tenir sa
partie contre elianov plutôt difficile
parce qu'il a un pion de moins et c'est
un vrai pion de moins puisque le
cavalier des quatre
et très très fort et si on les change
ben c'est voilà c'est horrible la
position
on a deux mois clés comme je disais
c'est c'est du coup un peu plus qui
tient il sert à tenir le cavalier des
quatre
ouais j'attends exactement
alors cavalue 3 alors là peut-être
manger je cavalier 5 mais il y aura
toujours quand même le pion en quatre en
l'air
alors il y a une meuf qui a eu dans sa
vie 27 70 un truc comme ça comme top
Hello
et les neuf c'est pas rigolo quand même
mais après je sais que dans les cadence
rapide tout ça c'est c'est un joueur qui
peut être prenable
donc bien sûr pour un joueur comme comme
métal
mais c'est un joueur qui est pas
forcément spécialiste de ces catégories
enfin de ces cadences très rapides
Eliano ça marche
super joueur mais pas forcément word de
Blitz quoi c'est ça
se bat pour te pour te défendre Kevin
alors que moi au traite de plagiste
ah tu peux nous faire un petit look
plagiste des fois et puis bon tu es
destination exotique
c'est sûr que
[Musique]
il y a plus de temps là qui va arriver
et tous cas un peu la figure je crois
ouais
et puis après peut-être un petit tour 2
autour de direct avoir dans des cinq
c'est bien c'est de Colombo du
professionnel on centralise on clou le
cavalier
ok tour 2
je pense direct
on peut on peut même aller
voir direct bon sans pour le voir après
en fait entre les Wacken priorité plutôt
live on a vu le résultat pas trop prévu
que le joueur indien
ben gagne contre la team indienne contre
le seul joueur qui n'est pas indien le
joueur iranien Tabata Baye voilà
du coup bah ça se bat encore ça se bat
jusqu'au bout
avec cette finale de dames sans doute
nulle et qui peut tourner en grande
importance quoi
il y a plein de pions qui avance de
partout
attention il y avait
moi j'aurais poussé tempo
et j'aurais perdu j'aurais perdu ce qui
va prendre la lune parce qu'il va
essayer de la jouer
ça joue un peu
[Musique]
forte alors est-ce que Davido elle
savait que c'est le score
quand il a pris nul je sais pas de toute
façon il n'a pas forcément de risque
ouais je pense que là il se dit c'est la
première onde et puis de toute façon
c'est objectivement nul
de risque à ce niveau là on a bien vu
caricat c'était une top player
enfin au monde et du coup il est
pragmatic aussi il a senti que dans la
partie c'était un peu chaud pas mauvais
résultats donc ça fait deux et demi 1 et
demi pour les nordway gnoms ils ont bien
optimisé à la victoire de prana va elle
fait du mal hein
3100 un truc comme ça donc bon c'est
hyper costaud et en plus il a il a aussi
un en a parlé mais le fait de savoir
qu'on a qu'il a fait nul contre moi ça
montre aussi enfin ça ça augmente un
petit peu on va dire son ça cote quoi
dans dans ce match c'est super super
joueur
comme ça c'est 4
qui va peut-être venir en 4 alors là
quand même l'impression que
tout tiens
S
je voulais amener le rang j'habite pour
faire la fourchette j'ai pas vu que je
l'avais avant un coup
d'attraction
assez rigolo
ouais
ok il faut acheter
la finale elle est très dure pour les
noirs avec ce pion passé protégé qui qui
est très très fort
échec le pion qui avance que derrière on
monte le roi et là c'est juste terminé
même échec pour garder la glace ce matin
là on va sacrifier le pion pour activer
notre roi je pense
S et donc on va de ce pas vous annoncer
le style et les apparisants pour pour
cette ronde de deux alors je les ai ici
et pas en maillot Jack il nous dit
n'importe quoi mayony claquette non je
pense pas il a un petit pull aujourd'hui
il se trouve j'ai l'impression oui oui
mais bon il fait bon en fait chez moi il
fait frais mais mais ici là c'est
clairement un temps pour aller à la
plage
bar avec cocktail et collier de fleurs
et des petites espagnoles je pense pas
j'ai ma copine à la maison donc c'est
forcément
contente mais après
après
le collier en fleur le cocktail oui
alors en fait c'est je me suis acheté
une une glacière ah ça c'est le top
quand tu vois la plage glacière mettez
le roi du monde en fait tu es le roi du
monde en fait tu sais une glacière
normale tout ce qui a de plus normal je
croyais tu mets tu mets des trucs à
l'intérieur
est-ce que tu veux
mais tu as par exemple tu mets bah je
sais pas tu peux mettre du coca là tu
peux mettre des bières tu peux mettre un
peu de rhum tu peux mettre un peu de
truc voilà et
non mais c'est génial en fait c'est ouf
il fait 32 degrés tu arrives avec ta
glacière avec tout tes glaçons mais mais
mais tu es le roi du monde tu es le roi
du monde en plus tu vois le transat les
gens ils disent que c'est cher parce que
tu as un Espagne et tout mais en fait tu
prends un transat tu as transat avec le
le
parasol ça coûte je pourrais 10 € pour
toute la famille et bon tu as ça et tu
as glacière hé franchement c'est génial
et
voilà donc oui oui donc la cocktail oui
et par contre j'ai pas le coller le
collier en fleurs mais bon
[Musique]
la chemise à fleurs la chemise à fleurs
aussi
quand même
c'est un peu chaud
le chat t'envie hein tu vois il y a Jack
qui qui rage entre autres mais je pense
que il y en a beaucoup à rager pendant
que pendant la France
après je vais peut-être y aller en fait
on pensait à y aller peut-être ce
weekend ou un truc comme ça mais moi tu
as entendu c'est cool franchement il
fait il fait tellement bon ici
ça c'est très agréable c'est sûr
comme en Bretagne
mais ouais c'est pas le même c'est pas
le même soleil c'est pas la même
température mais
[Musique]
moi après c'est cool ce weekend stouf je
dois aller remettre les lattes qui sont
tombées avec le vent qui a eu cette nuit
sur ma clôture voilà elles se sont
cassées la tronche parce que il y a trop
de vent voilà une bonne activité
surprise tu vois chacun ses plaisirs
je suis désolé de l'apprendre c'est pas
très grave c'est pas un gros truc mais
c'est juste fastidieux comme on dit
on est loin de la plage je peux te dire
on va attendre encore quelques mois
allez dans deux mois c'est bon dans deux
mois on va
moi ça fait déjà quelques semaines que
c'est bon
et c'est bon on peut y aller déjà
mais bon après il faut pas trop non plus
exagérer
travailler un peu quand même aussi
qu'on peut faire
qu'on peut faire en Bretagne attention
l'équipe de La Mézière est en passe de
monter en deuxième division je précise
deux départementales voilà
donc ça
dépend ça vaut le coup de sécher
l'approche League
je compte pas l'équipe
mes engagements sauf si je peux me faire
remplacer mais en ce moment on a un
courant on a des joueurs blessés c'est
tout tu sais que le battre c'est
traumatisant et on en a pas l'équipe la
plus jeune de notre championnat voilà
donc
[Musique]
du coup on souffre un petit peu
souffre un petit peu mais on se fait
plaisir
il y en a qui ont trouvé des idées en
Bretagne crêpes cidre c'est un peu
cliché quand même c'est un peu cliché
après le cidre c'est bon en vrai moi je
suis pas pas breton mais c'est vrai que
le cidre c'est sympa quoi
suivre à la plage c'est c'est un truc
que je pourrais tester en vrai c'est
quoi quand c'est bien frais et tout
c'est c'est quand même génial
par exemple
pastis je suis pas trop trop pastis j'ai
du mal
alors je suis du Sud mais
pas trop trop
tu vois je prends ça quand il y a plus
rien il fait pas le choix
non mais sinon je suis pas trop trop
hein non plus enfin le rouge par exemple
c'est pas mon truc parce qu'il fait trop
chaud
on t'offre un petit rosé bon ok ça va tu
vas ça passe
mais voilà tu vois je suis pas fan de de
tout ça je moi je moi ce que je préfère
c'est vraiment
[Musique]
c'est un un petit rhum frais tu vois ça
c'est avec du coca voilà ça c'est voilà
ça c'est c'est mon petit truc après il y
a d'autres choses mais mais bon
la bière j'arrive à
réguler et avoir une consommation
modeste si je fais du sport sinon c'est
la caramel quoi
avec l'âge avec l'âge plutôt pas ok
peut-être
donc je comprends ce que tu dis ça me
parle ça me parle vraiment belle
discussion en tout cas on a on a dérivé
un petit peu mais bon voilà c'est le la
pose
on est
à la moitié de la première mi-temps on
peut dire ça comme ça c'est ça donc là
j'ai tout réglé pour la ronde 2 qui va
démarrer du coup dans quelques instants
d'ailleurs qui a démarré dans depuis
quelques instants ça va être serré de
regarder
troposki avec fougères 5
assez marrante avec alors c'est
peut-être pas ici non c'est pas là du
tout il y a une ligne au Maroc comment
je connais bien enfin ce qu'ils ont joué
c'est la ligne grande classique
toi tu voulais me montrer E5 non non en
fait il y a une ligne et c'est pas
celle-là donc je parlais en fait une
ligne avec un dame B6 genre je crois que
c'était celle-là et genre sur ça je veux
dame B6 fousse1 non c'est un quelques
secondes intéressant
toujours dans son style atypique au
niveau des ouvertures la trompe
c'est est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer
l'idée de secours Kevin déjà touche pas
la structure donc ça évite de toucher
les pions les affaiblir et en plus on
joue pour le centre on a obtenu ce qu'on
voulait et du coup on va jouer pour E4
tout simplement et on évite on évite de
jouer un B3 qui serait bizarre en fait
dans cette position le foin F4 il est
pas si fort que ça parce qu'on aime se
faire un jour 4 peut-être pour pour tout
balancer et cavalier prof ou des trois
et voilà grosse expansion au centre même
peut-être ces cartes à un moment et
c'est important vraiment de pas toucher
à ses pions il y a beaucoup de gens qui
des fois sur un truc comme ça ils vont
faire de manière automatique un B3 et
vous allez voir qu'au final après un fou
G7 tout qui va s'ouvrir et il y a plein
de problèmes en fait sur la structure et
d'encaisser de pas toucher vos pions si
c'est pas 100% obligatoire parce que
vous savez un peu ça ne recule pas
donc là lui ce qu'il veut c'est la
structure
parfaitement expliqué aussi parce que B3
il y avait G6 et du coup après la
diagonale sur la Touraine était mortelle
au pénible en tout cas
comment ça s'appelle cette ligne la
Snake
c'est un truc comme ça bon là ça va être
dur de le faire mais il y a une ligne
avec avec fou à 5 pour aller manger ce
cavalier C3 pour fermer
j'activement c'est pas la ligne de folie
mais ici c'est bien mieux parce que très
vite on va jouer pour tour 8
et dames C7
pièces avec ce cavalier 2
en tout cas c'est assez atypique on fait
un petit tour des ouvertures comme ça
alors je sais pas où changer à chaque
fois tous les tous les trucs là
bon bah du coup ça on peut vous dire
c'est un peu pénible c'est une italienne
et on trouve pas ça rigolo enfin c'est
bon enfin c'est pas possible
ok donc une partie à jouer en tout cas
il va faire cavaler la fin G3 sûrement
et puis dans ces positions là c'est des
choix souvent pas terribles parce que le
fait un petit peu malmener comme tu le
montres que soit avec G4 ou cavalier F1
cavalier G3 et souvent il se retrouve
coincé en G6
c'est assez mal inspiré généralement de
jouer le fou en G4
faut G6 cavalier j'ai trois pour venir
en F5 et si tu en prends on prend du
pion g pour me mettre le rond H2 la
tourangère et obtenir du coup la colonne
g pour attaquer le roi c'est intéressant
ce fou comme tu dis il va le placer très
souvent dans ces positions on se connaît
bien faire plutôt c'est de jouer un
petit H6 bon petit rock H6 est joué fou
aussi c'est un tour il faut aussi pour
échanger il faut de cases blanches c'est
plus thématique et une fois que les fous
sont échangés jouent avec des 5 pour
ouvrir la position
mais c'est vrai que fuj4 c'est bizarre
ok bon while
Tourer
au départ et puis après il y a eu la
formation avec E5 qui laisse un trou en
D5 mais qui contrôle bien le centre
c'est ça a pris aussi un trou en B5
aussi donc plusieurs plans pour les
blancs ici donc on a ce plan là qui est
qui est connu on va manœuvrer le
cavalier pour arriver sur la case des 5
et on a aussi ce plan avec le cavalier
même là pour jeb4 plus tard sur le long
terme donc c'est deux petits plans
intéressants c'est marrant d'ailleurs
parce que
ce Foulet 5 me choque un petit peu sauf
et c'est intéressant de voir parce que
je connaissais le plan que tu as indiqué
là en fait il a visé la supériorité
numérique sur casse blanche il a vu que
les cases blanches étaient ouvertes et
il veut juste travailler sur case
blanche et enterrer le fou G7 avec ce
choix là volontaire de donner son coup
de case noire puisqu'il a vu que les
trous étaient sur blanc il y a une
position un peu similaire alors si je
peux me permettre je recommande depuis
le début il y a une ligne dans la
Sicilienne avec tous les cinq échecs et
quand tu joues avec par exemple fulpron
faut prendre cavalier prend
avec C4 E5 et ben on a une idée un peu
similaire ou en fait on va jouer avec
fougères 5 pour échanger ici avec l'idée
que maintenant peu importe tu vas manger
et ben je vais mettre un cavalier hop
hop ici et après l'échange de cavaliers
un peu au hasard juste pour montrer un
peu l'idée donc
cavalier super contre un fou qui est
derrière sa structure de pion et après
ben éventuellement jouer à trois B4
petit rock etc et les Blancs ont une
très bonne position avec avec bon
cavalier contre un fou qui pourra jamais
venir échanger et là en fait
ce que veut peut-être également c'est
sur le long terme arriver à une position
un peu similaire c'est à dire que s'il
arrive à échanger lutte contre lui et
lui contre lui regarde là il va
commencer le mode truc hein
ensemble et je m'incave et là et un jour
peut-être tu vas changer un cavaler
contre cavaliers et ensuite
on va ramener une position à deux
résultats c'est ce que ce stuff fallait
nous dire après bon cavalier contre
mauvais fou c'est une souffrance sur le
long terme très désagréable
stratégiquement on se fait travailler et
du coup c'est dur dur
maintenant je suis beaucoup plus dans la
construction et je vois des cases je me
dis tiens que c'est intéressant il y a
pas trop le choix parce que je me suis
vu attaquer des forces grand-mère comme
ça un peu avec F5 F4 et puis bah perdre
la partie au final le mec se défend vous
a faibli
sur d'autres endroits que l'endroit où
vous l'attaquez il contrôle votre
attaque et vous fait mal sur le long
terme
il y a du B4 ici qui va arriver il y a
du cavalier E3 qui avait des 5 pub et 4
en tout cas ça va être l'idée un peu de
mettre ici donc ça va être je pense une
partie intéressante regardez moi qui
m'intéresse beaucoup celle-là
et du coup chez Owell et ATI
h Adida mital que vous avez juste ici
alors vous avez les noms mais c'est pas
les vrais noms je vais vous les enlever
du coup
ouais bon là c'est une position qui a
l'air assez égale et c'est pas c'est
quoi c'est une
Espagne oui ok fameuse
Berlin anti Berlin quoi
et du coup
les Blancs n'ont obtenu rien du tout et
c'est extrêmement solide les pièces
devraient s'échanger on pourrait voir un
match nul en tout cas on n'a pas dépensé
de temps et la vidéo elle n'a pas été
très inspiré contre le début solide joué
par les noirs sans doute un peu
dubitatif le gars le gars David on voit
qu'il a pas l'air passionné par sa
position il doit faire pareil pourtant
donc c'est un peu compliqué ce qui se
passe pour lui avec les Blancs
et voir ce qui se passe mais
même la dame F4 par exemple c'était pas
forcément un bon coup est-ce que c'est
possible de de manger là et de jouer
cavaler contre mauvais
fouteur classe pour ce match donc
en fait voilà avec les pions sur casse
blanche et Ben se foutent devient pas
très bon et du coup notre cavalier il
est atteignable
l'échange fou cavalier aux échecs est
tellement récurrent que il faut être
vraiment très au courant parce que tout
le monde a son niveau d'amateur et
confronté à ce genre de prise de
décision l'échange fu cavaliers font le
maîtriser aux échecs avec le jeu de
couleur bon cavalier mauvais fou c'est
des termes qui doivent vous parler en
tout cas c'est ça
du coup dans les cavaliers ici là il est
hors de question qu'on donne ce cavalier
et du coup à 4 comprendre l'espace
là-bas
ouais c'est intéressant de jouer des
jeux pour A5 à 6 parce que déjà si
jamais il me laisse faire un 5 et qui me
laisse faire un six et pas on va forcer
baisser c'est là sur 15 branche quand
même vous pour être intéressant je pense
et aussi sur
tempo et c'est toujours assise juste
pour montrer un peu ce qui se passe
du coup c'est pas mais dans votre si je
joue avec ça ben peut-être plus tard
j'ai des idées de pouvoir pousser à
majorité et ouvrir un peu la position
pour mon fou donc à 5 ici avait là il
perd standard il va peut-être jouer
jusqu'à F6 après il va peut-être jouer à
5 paraly
à 5
hello à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent le
route alors David hawael c'est c'est un
des des joueurs de l'équipe olympique
d'Angleterre qui est aussi un des
entraîneurs de Carlsen
Owell c'est un genre qui a quasiment
enfin qui a eu 2700 dans sa vie
et un joueur qui
est très très fort et mital c'est un
joueur indien qui qui je crois qu'il est
tout jeune grand maître comme il le
savent pas encore il manquait im mais je
crois qu'il est grand maître depuis peu
et 2500 et il est jeune donc c'est un
très bon 4e échec qui est donc toi il a
pas peur d'envoyer
l'Utal donc H5 H4 il veut rendre ce
cavalier un peu
pas très bon mais en fait il y en a un
qui attaquent le roi
bon sauf j'aurais bien voulu la même
idée à chaque auquel je n'avais pas
pensé directement ici j'aurais fait à 5
d'abord et ensuite travailler mais il
avait peur de B4 peut-être ou des choses
comme ça tout de suite c'était chaud à
jouer ces trois B4
là il y a aussi l'idée c'est que plus
tard c'est que tu joues H4 qui a valu
deux j'imagine et ben j'ai quand même
des idées plus tard peut-être avec du
Tour à 4 qui peut venir attaquer ce pion
sur le transfert des pièces qui peut
venir attaquer plus tard le roi noir ça
peut être une idée sur le long terme en
tout cas
X4 ou cavalier 4 faire des choses
nous-mêmes aux quatre provoque peut-être
il faut 4 provoque C4
est-ce que j'ai pas non plus un coup
comme tour à 4 qui est possible
du coup
de la dame aussi
mais on sent que noir sorti quand même
c'est assez ok mais faire attention
parce que c'est coup de pions quand même
plus tard ça peut aussi être un
réblissement tu vois si jamais j'arrive
à échanger des pièces un petit peu sur
le long terme on a plus confiance
elle a poussé blanche ouais
si on arrive à échanger les dames on
pourra peut-être travailler un peu la
pause rien n'est fait c'est ça
on est reparti pour pour la suite alors
tabac Tabe est-ce qu'il a réussi à déjà
faire des goupillés ça le jeune
opposante ou pas du tout ça a pas l'air
du tout bon qu'est-ce qui est on avait
annoncé tu sais
de la difficulté pour
pour la jeune Chelsea
et en fait elle est en train de faire du
mal à ta bataille
c'est assez étonnant
on critiquait Souf ouais j'ai 4 rapide
incroyable que ce soit si bien passé
qui est très forte
et d'ailleurs après tour des 8 alors je
sais pas laquelle une des deux
sauce du voyage
et c'est ça mais bon
c'est un coup
parce que je blesse quand même
pour l'instant tu as pas tu as pas la
tour en soutien en fait
et le fou qui serait pas terrible
direct qui me donnait comme le contrôle
de la position
intéressant et
cette partie et cette fameuse trop ski
qui était assez intéressantes au final
ou irrégaliser comme d'habitude avec un
roi acrobatique pour te reprendre tout
que là
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait notre ami
le partenaire de club
il a un pion net
ah non il est d'accord c'est la qualité
en fait il a envoyé une qualité
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé rapidement
rapidement on va essayer de reprendre
donc il a fait G4
G4 ambitieux
l'attaque la fleur au fusil comme dirait
certain
[Musique]
très très belle cette partie il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'initiatives là les
pièces blanches sortent pas j'aimais
bien faux 3 pour dompter les cases
noires sauf pas pourquoi il a pas joué à
la place de de dames en B5
avec la cavalier qui arrive en F4
[Musique]
et là c'est dur qu'est-ce que je voulais
est-ce que
comme B4 mais prends c'est trop encore
tout à l'heure dommage
de sortir un peu de ma coquille
pas mal je pense tout pour proposer
ouais j'aurais fait dames
parce que t'as pas cavalier B6 puisque
la dame est en baisse
5 à un moment pour essayer de d'échanger
les pièces
[Musique]
bon après c'était pas mal
un peu plus actif
et
les blancs parce qu'on a beau avoir une
tour de plus regardez la qualité de plus
elle est en H1
on a laissé comme les montres comme le
monde tout les pièces au garage
alors
est-ce qu'il y a pas un petit coup sympa
de roi et fuite qui viennent un roi et
fuite avec tout 8
alors j'étais en train de penser moi
j'ai enlevé maths
cavalier 3 soufflant
ce qui veut dire que d'un prof à
interdit ils ont Caval le 3 front et 3
j'aurais pu prendre les 7 dans 3 C4
c'est pareil à cavalier 3 avec 3 alors
là c'est pas possible que ça tienne
donc mon partenaire de club là il a
grande difficulté contre pranave la
dernière fois que j'avais vu jouer prana
il avait joué de manière très moyenne
mais rapide et là il joue extrêmement
bien il joue plus lentement et
extrêmement bien
là il est pas mal prenne avant quand
dans ce petit truc là dans cette partie
alors j'ai 5 alors là c'est chaud là il
y a du calcul de partout
faut prendre je prends ta dame tu prends
la mienne
pas envie sûrement
tu vois en tout cas j'ai pas vu mais
erikasi il a le petit t-shirt pro deci
avec son petit logo mgda il l'avait déjà
la dernière fois ça a bien fait marrer
OK et là son t-shirt c'est le seul
d'ailleurs je crois il y en a pas
beaucoup capitaine d'équipe
il est très pro très très
par contre la position qui est là
la même menace
de trouver une défense il faut qu'il
bouge la dame mais bon
appelle l'acrobate donc il est capable
dans cette position de non pas de de
faire un miracle mais de tenir tenir et
faire craquer
qui sait qu'il a une star face à lui en
Inde regalizi c'est quelque chose
savoir qu'il est gagnant de savoir qu'il
a de grosses compensations il voit les
pièces qui sont braquées sur le roi ils
voient la tour-acha qui est une partie
sur la partie raisin proposeront H3 moi
j'ai fait la grimace en disant non
franchement c'est pas possible et au
moment où je fais la flèche de Rouen H3
et ben ça a été joué incroyable alors
moi je crois c'est un coup Éric
irrigasiek si je peux dire réponse à roi
je crois pour jouer le jeu
toujours le petit Hachette j'avoue que
c'est assez incroyable ce coup
moi moins clair
je pensais à cavalue 3 d'un B7
ça me si
c'est une grosse menace sur fulprom
cavalier prend il y a la dame en prise
de fouet le pur F3 en prise plein
d'échecs partout
qu'on voit c'est extrêmement chaud
ils ont plus de temps la pendule ils ont
plus de 30 secondes chacun enfin 20
secondes pour la gazy qui a l'air très
calme
magazine
est-ce qu'on ferait un petit j'avais
prévu de dessiner 3 c'est pas mal je
voulais rusé avec des 5 fous d'essai
il faut le finir plusieurs fois
8 c'est bien aussi calmos
ce sont levés qu'avait les prendre en F3
et peut-être
H3 x 5
c'est très dur j'ai 6 peut-être avec
dommage 5 d'un point H3
ta page 2 dames 2 et la tortilla
grosse grosse partie en tout cas de
pranave pradavre qui ouvre le score
alors tabac abeille qu'est-ce qui donne
chez dans cette deuxième partie
qui est pas content
qui est qui est très contente
qu'il y a un grand sourire
bien joué
et juste pour reprendre c'est abondant
on avait
on avait enterré la jeune châssis qui va
être
raviewé
7 et puis et puis c'est abandon
c'est abandon incroyable cette partie
incroyable il s'en veut un Tabata Bay
elle est hyper contente il vient de
perdre deux fois de rang et elle était
ravie vous l'avez vu à l'écran
ouais et du coup à Rica
Arika qui a les Noirs contre tabataba et
qui a du coup des pions qui vont avancer
le roi actif et d'ailleurs qui a gagné
qui a gagné après quoi le 4 avec
la tour c'est assez mignon et dans la
partie du coup de Owell avec les Blancs
qui est toujours mal au temps contre
contre mital
vous mettre les noms du joueur noir
surtout à l'aile d'arme là où la tour B6
est complètement coincé
ça a l'air très très difficile de jouer
des coups avec les Noirs la tour B6
complètement dominée
on a des résultats de folie dans cette
dans cette ronde avec les deux féminines
de deux équipes qui ont battu des
superstars c'est clair et là avec le
point de David awell qui est en train
c'est quand même un gros avantage blanc
ici et ben ça pourrait mettre vraiment
très très mal les les Indiens qui
seraient menés au 5 et demi à deux et
demi
et c'est ce qui va se passer je vous le
dis la vidéo elle va gagner et
heureusement que Harry car a battu el
Jana finalement le match serait
quasiment foutu
c'est à la faveur de cette victoire que
que les Indiens sont en vie mais
les trois les trois gars qui sont censés
avoir
l'expérience
on perdue mais ils sont forts à faire
aussi tu nous avais dit stuff tu aurais
dû parier c'est
que moi j'aime pas parler complètement
tu sais tu sais les féminines c'est pas
si grave que ça c'est les mecs qui
changent carrément d'avis tu sais
avoir une équipe soudée
c'est seulement 2266 par rapport à
Tabata Bay qui est quasiment 27 il est
toujours entre 26,50 et 27
c'est en cadence 10 + 2 mais c'est une
énorme perf si vous avez vu
on a l'impression qu'elle avait pleuré
tellement elle était contente c'est une
perte qui est exceptionnelle
exceptionnel c'est monstrueux
des jeunes femmes ce tournoi était
extrêmement difficile ce qu'on joue
toute l'équipe adverse et quand on a une
jeune femme à 2002 2003 et qu'on joue la
féminine adverse à 2500 plus dégâts en
moyenne à 2006-2017 c'est trop trop dur
là bravo à elle elle a fait une super
partie ouais du coup ça nous fait un 5
et demi deux et demi pour les norwegnoms
au bout de deux sept là on est
clairement la moitié du du temps enfin
du temps en commentaire on est à deux
sets sur quatre
ouais donc juste une petite chose là
vous savez que pour gagner la partie
enfin pour gagner le match il faut
arriver à 8 points et demi si
nordwegnoms met trois un donc 3 1 donc
réitère le score de ce Zelda lors du
prochain set le match sera fini il y
aura pas de quatrième set du coup
bon je pense que ça va jouer enfin je
pense pas que 3 1 2 fois d'affilée ce
serait quand même beaucoup
alors tabataba il est vraiment pas en
forme il est en train de plomber son
équipe
parce que il peut pas se permettre quand
même il a fait il a fait bulle
on s'y attendait pas ouais c'est ça
c'est une perte qui est quasi comparable
en fait à celle mais peut-être pas quand
même mais Nakamura contre
contre
Joséphine Hyman c'est pas vraiment
comparable parce que ma caméra qui aime
bien plus fort mais mais c'est une perte
qui franchement
tu vois sur 10 parties
je la voyais pas en gagner une seule
fois
voilà sans vouloir indiscréditer un peu
la joueuse mais tabataba c'est tellement
fort en fait
que c'est dur quoi aussi
ils sont plusieurs fais attention à tous
les T-Shirts
mais il a aussi son petit t-shirt sympa
je vous mets les caméras pour la rendre
enfin pour la pour la partie d'après
tu me dis si tu veux faire une petite
pause
tout à l'heure ce qu'on a parlé
si tu veux
moi je m'en fous moi je mets les caméras
suivant une petite pause on peut se la
faire c'est comme tu préfères
pose de 5 minutes à leur souffle allez
ça marche on arrive dans à peu près même
moins de 5 minutes parce que eux ils ont
pas de pause ouais 3 minutes ça marche à
tout de suite
non comme ça je vais prendre un truc
t'inquiète je vais vous mettre en pause
je vais vous mettre si vous voulez
attendez
je vais vous mettre qu'est-ce que je
voulais une petite vidéo tiens à tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes revenus
nous sommes revenus du coup avec Kevin
et là vous voyez à l'écran d'avis dewell
qui va affronter
irrigasi dans un instant donc là c'est
le troisième set et les 3e et 4e 7 sont
d'ailleurs les deux sets les plus les
plus serrées en termes de
en termes de de jeu
option prise par les normes on
s'attendait pas à cela ils font deux
points ils sont vraiment ballotage hyper
favorables
ils ont deux points à faire dans cette
ronde très clairement et après ils
seront plus peinard sauf pour pour
l'emporter voilà le job à faire ne pas
perdre ici le minimat ils seront ils
seront ok on s'attendait pas à ça très
clairement je pense que enfin moi très
clairement je pariais sur les l'équipe
d'erégasis et toi c'est pareil non
j'aurais je t'attendais une perche pour
voir ce que vous voulez parier mais bon
j'ai vite compris qu'il y a quasi voilà
compagnon de club
d'ailleurs tu les feras la facture de
tous les sœurs que tu me dois
c'est clair c'est clair il m'a fait du
mal
on fait du mal c'est clair
donc en tout cas gros match et c'est
Erika qui a battu aljanov aussi souffre
dans dans la partie précédente qui
maintient l'équipement sinon il y avait
6 et demi 1 et demi incroyable il y a
vraiment pas mal de paires dans dans ce
match là et maintenant on attaque les
matchs équilibrés pour cette fin de
gros gros s'affiche
au niveau classement on vous rappelle
que l'équipe qui l'emporte se qualifie
en plus pour la suite
tandis que l'autre équipe reste en vie
mais ben voilà c'est ça il faut arriver
à trois points trois matchs gagnés pour
se qualifier et après après ce match là
il reste encore une ronde pour se
qualifier donc là l'équipe qui gagne
maintenant se qualifie du coup pour le
deuxième but final et pour les carpes
tandis que
l'équipe qui perdra aujourd'hui aura
encore une chance encore un match à
jouer pour se qualifier pour du coup
voilà donc c'est pas encore terminé mais
c'est vrai que c'est une belle option là
qu'ils ont pris les lard Magnum avec 5
mois et demi on va du coup hier 45 45
qui a perdu du coup son match avec son
équipe et qu'il est on ne sait pas
qualifié pour pour la suite car ce qui
est éliminé
dans la partie qui vient de commencer à
l'instant donc ça c'est David away la
clé blanc contre irrigazi donc une
partie assez équilibrée
en plus David
avec les pièces blanches
il faut pas qu'il force de trop
faut pas qu'il perd en tout cas très
clairement pour son équipe il y a plus
trop le droit à l'erreur clairement
très très mal parti là l'équipe l'équipe
indienne bon après ils ont une équipe
légèrement plus faible j'ai l'impression
de la dernière fois encore que corco il
doit être il doit être très proche d'un
moyen-élo max quand même
une jeune femme à 2500 de toute façon
il avait joué déjà
[Musique]
de jouer quelque chose de tranquille
pour te régalizi
c'est un joueur qui adore les pollutions
hyper chaude et donc lui bah j'ai un
truc tranquille en essayant de je pense
quand même une nulle c'est un bon
résultat pour les blancs sachant que le
vieux enfin vu le score pour l'instant
il est clair qu'il a pas envie de se
prendre la tête
ça c'est clair et il a bien raison de
jouer un truc solide donc bien sûr
ces petits systèmes un peu bizarre et il
veut du coup
se met un peu le doute donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe après c'est prank qu'elle
va les prendre ça fait un peu pour un
carton
comme ça
il y a rien de de compromettant ce sont
plutôt des lignes normales
on doit pouvoir jouer même avec des cinq
aussi c'est la partie est-ce que tu fais
un petit tour des stades du coup voir un
peu ce qui se passe dans les ouvertures
on voit quelle partie on va choisir
comme grand format et puis on voit des
ouvertures distinctes
alors Eliano ici contre tabac Tabe qui
vient de perdre contre Chelsea
on dirait que voir de foot qui vient de
perdre celle-ci et du coup qui a
clairement un coeur de se refaire donc
là c'est une une Espagne une Sicilienne
donc
directement d'ailleurs faux A4 j'ai
jamais vu
donc c'est Mathieu cornette qui avait
joué ça dans une partie je sais pas si
c'est ici mais il y avait eu ce genre de
schéma
ou une sorte de marozzi quoi si vous
voulez ce qu'on est en train de voir
donc c'est trois des quatre pour le
centre et là bon on est dans une
domination
où on va jouer sur quatre engins et
l'adversaire sur sur trois rangées donc
c'est un bon choix calme aussi deljana
avec les Blancs
le petit plus des ouvertures assez
Malines avec et je crois blanc sont
assez pertinents par rapport à la
physionomie du match et on va voir alors
on va voir il y a un Rica qui joue aussi
contre la jeune Chelsea est-ce que c'est
le site qui vient de battre tabac
Tabeille du coup avec avec les Noirs
italiens salut à tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent salut Yuma on va salut à tous
et du coup cette ligne elle est marrante
parce que moi du coup je joue un peu
pareil à l'époque regarde les
transpositions que tu peux faire pour
jouer un dragon accéléré donc moi la
honte cavaler prendre des cartes
d'apprendre des cartes et des 6
les positions c'est le même un peu
partout trois choix assez solides de la
part des blancs
position plus agréable je quitte pas
loin qui a vu la vidéo ah ouais c'est
ouf c'est ouf cette vidéo
c'est un documentaire du match castor
et c'est vraiment génial je l'ai mis
hier sur le sur le sur le chat on en
parlait un petit peu par rapport à la
valorisation des pièces souvent en fait
tu sais par exemple un exemple de
Kasparov qui disait ouais j'ai une
position là j'ai 7 pièces à l'attaque
contre 3 bah je fais un échange de
l'attaquant pour faire défenseur donc
c'était cavalier propion H6 tu vois sans
réfléchir il doit je réfléchis pas parce
que là à la fin j'ai c'est attaquant
qu'on défenseur c'est un contrat tu vois
en fait en vrai c'est un carnet ça vaut
trois points et un point ça va point ça
vaut 1 mais explique comme ça il disait
qu'il a pas calculé bon après quand tu
donnes une pièce
mais voilà il le dit de manière tu vois
oui bien sûr qu'il a calculé mais je
pense qu'il a pas tout et voilà c'était
plus un instant ça exactement mais il a
vu des trucs il a vu qu'il y avait du
jeu parce qu'il est pas débile quand
même il est champion du monde il y a eu
le match pour garder son titre
et il va pas il va pas s'envoyer en
l'air en totale
donc F3 on va faire à 5 et 15 et 17
bizarrement dans ces positions là en
échange le foot case noire bizarrement
c'est logique d'un point de vue des
pièces mais perdre le Fougeret pour la
sécurité du roi il y en a qui auraient
peur de faire cela alors que le roi noir
est très difficile à attaquer c'est pour
ça qu'on échange on propose l'échange
qui est souvent refusé d'ailleurs par
les Blancs qui reviennent en F2 ou E3
selon les cas et là quand vous regardez
les pièces aussi les pièces des blancs
et des Noirs en fait la moins bonne
pièce des Noirs ben c'est le fou c'est 6
qui qui a pas trop de cases et chez les
Blancs bonne pièce c'est aussi le fou et
deux donc du coup ce qui est intéressant
c'est une fois qu'on échange les fous de
case noire des fois il y a un cavalier
blanc qui peut venir en dessin et là du
coup on va manger pour Jacques cavalier
contre le mauvais fou E2 le fou qui est
mauvais derrière sa structure de pion
après ça dépend des fois le fou peut
être fort s'il y a des bonnes positions
ou le fou peut devenir fort mais d'un
point de vue stratégique c'est une idée
qu'on peut avoir avec les Noirs
clairement de jeux pour changer les
pièces du coup faut s'en occuper en
premier c'est pour ça que les Noirs ils
avaient vu que le fousser 8 avait un peu
de mal il vous fout des 7 foussaisses
comme tu l'as expliqué pour essayer de
valoriser en priorité sa mauvaise pièce
il faut deux lui il a du mal il a du mal
dans ses positions mais on a l'Espace on
peut pas tout avoir les échecs c'est un
jeu de concession à part quand on a une
position écrasante ok on se fait plaisir
mais sinon il faut concéder des choses à
l'adversaire il faut essayer de
considérer moins que ce que l'on obtient
en échange et ça c'est pas facile les
positions sont en perpétuel mouvement
elles sont tendues
OK et du coup là dans la partie les deux
jeunes Indiens qui s'affrontent
donc ouh là là c'est une un reposer donc
je pense c'est une sorte de écossaise
avec cavalier métro un truc comme ça non
c'est un bon pragmatique ou B6 ks-3 on
sort la dame on met le fond en E3 et on
pourra jouer avec grand rock et balancer
une attaque recomposée donc ceux qui
aiment bien s'amuser aux échecs vous
voyez que là vous allez pouvoir balancer
du HK du G4 etc
a le pion B
et c'est une ouverture qui est
intéressant
il faut aimer aussi les positions
tendues comme ça il y a des joueurs qui
n'aiment pas les positions trop tendues
des fois
des fois quand c'est trop tendu
ben
c'est compliqué quoi mais
la roulette alors que les trois autres
positions c'est la totale maîtrise mais
on voit le style un peu jeune d'ailleurs
de ces joueurs qui sont 25 ou 25 50
bientôt plus ils sont très calculatoires
capables d'aller dans les grosses basses
sont et au fur et à mesure qu'il
s'affirme ils seront aussi capables
d'aller dans des positions beaucoup plus
plates et d'être très précis il faut
être complet aujourd'hui si on veut
atteindre 26-2650 27 on voit les gens
savent tout faire
particulièrement
attends je peux je peux te laisser
quelques secondes
il part en nous laissant la belle la
belle grande Feld de
mon chat qui crie comme un taré il est
tout seul à la maison je sais pas ce qui
lui arrive j'arrive
donc du coup ici qu'est-ce que l'on joue
cavalier C4 fait pression sur B2 le
cavalier C3 attention il est visé par le
fou G7 souvent on peut placer la dame en
B3 dans ce genre de position pour
contrôler les deux cavaliers est-ce que
c'est la meilleure case il a choisi E2
en les deux étaient complètement
jouables
et maintenant on va faire on a la paire
de fou alors il y en a qui ont vu
peut-être le petit pion H3 en l'air mais
c'est un leurre il y a fuj G4 qui
enferme la dame donc on va pouvoir faire
tout FD un tour C1 je peux vous dire la
position de la vidéo elle et l'alerte
beaucoup plus simple à jouer
c'est cool ça y est vraiment agréable on
a la paire de fou et le plan dans ce
type de position ça pourrait être de
s'étendre au centre avec E5 donc tourner
un tour C1 on place les pièces les tours
n'ont pas été activées donc on va les
mettre sur les colonnes semi-ouvertes et
comme ça ça nous permettrait de prévoir
les C6 et aussi noir qui devraient être
joué pour
taper le centre blanc ça allait ton chat
sauf oui bon c'est typique mais là
c'était un peu chaud parce que je
l'avais jamais entendu
miauler aussi fort
mais en fait oui souvent en fait
on lui a acheté une petite peluche
et on lui a donné et en fait à chaque
fois qu'elle miaule commence et qu'elle
est trop contente en fait elle pleure de
joie en jouant c'est marrant
et à chaque fois donc la nuit pour lui
enlève la peluche parce que des fois
hors du matin
mais du coup
du coup là mais là je me doutais que
c'était ça mais là c'était vraiment
tellement fort comme tu dis bon je sais
pas si tu arrives un truc quoi
on sait jamais là c'était là c'était
vraiment très fort et
donc que ça à la maison et ben
je suis allé voir ouais mais elle avait
la elle avait l'ours à la bouche
ok d'accord
marrant
du coup
je pense
du coup un petit cavalier et qui va
venir en D6
j'aime beaucoup
on peut jouer pas pourquoi je donnerais
mon fou en tout cas et B3 fois 3 et
tourcer un et il y aura peut-être
réaction noire à F5
surveiller l'histoire du pion H3 qui est
en l'air toute la partie mais il y a
fougère pour l'instant vous savez mais à
un moment où mon fou irait en A3
peut-être moi je crois pas qu'on puisse
le prendre parce qu'il y a toujours
je te dis ça enfin tu me dis que tu
crois pas mais moi non plus j'y crois
pas mais
ergy
j'ai envie de te parier un petit sceptre
qui va bouffer le curage froid cette
partie
je suis obligé de parier tu as réussi à
ma voix
on est sur
allez c'est pareil j'arrive sur une
bonne anecdote en tout cas et toi Kevin
quel genre de peluche pourrait te faire
pleurer de joie
simplement un chat ou un chien pas des
lots tu sais je pense je suis allergique
voilà donc les peluches pas mes grands
amis les chats et les chiens moyens quoi
voilà
bon froid c'est bien
H3 un moment ça serait terrible affaires
ce petit
en plus il suffit de jouer H4 Souf
[Rires]
le sens était quand même que le pion
soit pris en H3 je réclame au chat un
soutien par rapport à ça
je te l'accorde et du coup c'est une
belle côte que je t'ai fait du coup
obligé de parier je suis obligé de
parier mais attention ça peut ce genre
de pari peut se retourner
la finale turfu tu sais elle a été
perdue tofu contour je vous rappelle
c'est nulle théorique et avec tout on a
pris le pari bon c'était peut-être 55
ans à ce moment-là que riazon allait
tenir pour la finale avec la tour et en
fait il a perdu en 15 secondes et comme
Ryan de SAF et d'origine russe on dit
que c'est un pays de final je trouvais
assez logique de lui faire confiance
quoi il m'avait particulièrement déçu et
ça avait fait bien rigoler ce souffle
qui a gagné mais vraiment mais 15
secondes peut-être le sub et c'était
toujours un peu d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs
le même joueur qui a perdu le même
tournoi qui a perdu tour fou contre
contre non roi tour contre roi fou
il faudra qu'il bosse un peu les finales
parce qu'il a perdu les deux finales
dans le même tournoi et en fin de
carrière il a été
je suis pas bien dans cette quête là
dans la quête
parce que ça peut se passer sur un
ça va être terrible la finale tu sais
moi je crois final de Tours c'est le roi
qui va nous montrer
vous comprenez pourquoi ah magnifique
magnifique David il a entendu superbe ça
donne des casques
ouais il a bien compris le foot casse
blanche devait s'exprimer et là on a
vraiment une très très belle inspiration
pour le jeu de couleur évidemment
souffle
c'est très bien joué bon moi je suis un
peu deg par rapport à mon pari mais du
coup le pur ça recule pas donc je suis
trop une Dead et lui il peut même pas
aller ici enfin en fait à moins qu'il ne
présente pas ascendant il y a même pas
de présentation en fait j'ai perdu quoi
j'essaie de reculer mon pion un truc
mais non je crois que c'est impossible
de montage 3 non c'est pas possible non
je peux pas
dur dur
ok est-ce que moi un petit tour du coup
rapide alors du coup dans cette partie
qui a les blancs au tabac Tabe donc un
tabac tabac revanchard
donc il y a une bonne position quand
même pour toi ta règle avec les Noirs
parce que il y a 15 à 5 qui est très
forte avec les pions ici qui sont
bloqués sur casse blanche un peu faible
ce petit pion dessin qui est 4 je vais
fracasser les pions et les fous vont
s'échanger donc on aura les meilleures
pièces ça peut faire nul quand même
cette position mais il va souffrir pour
l'obtenir qui est pas en grande forme
non plus c'est là le duel des joueurs un
peu cagoule dans ce mini match
mais belle position qu'elle pourtant
qui a les noirs et qui est mieux autant
et en tant que blitzer ben moi je te dis
moi j'ai j'avais beaucoup mixé avec
tabac abeille quand on était en Top 12
et il était monstrueux quoi c'était
vraiment très impressionnant je crois
que toute la semaine
toute la semaine on glisser contre lui
tous les gens de l'équipe enfin je parle
pas des Indiens je parle juste de nous
tu sais tous les Guillaume Lamarre les
Garris du Royan les Romulus et il y
avait moi aussi on est tous entre 2003
et 2004 50 etc
on est pas des très très bons joueurs
mais on se bat quoi et quand même sur
une semaine de but avec lui on l'a pas
pris une seule quoi mais tous mélangé
quoi ça veut dire ça c'est monstrueux et
par contre direct à l'école quoi alors
que bon moi si je veux le contraire je
me sentir
et pourtant elle l'a dit direct et c'est
ouf
et voilà alors que je l'avais joué pas
mal sur Internet aussi également
du tout je l'avais pris plusieurs
parties d'ailleurs j'avais peut-être
fait un deux ou trois victoires
contre beaucoup de défaites mais j'avais
pas été ridicule du tout et j'ai
l'impression que enfin sur un petit
match entre Eliana et tabataba en blitz
c'est ben je parlerai plus sur tabacar
il joue beaucoup enfin tu vois Eliano je
pense que c'est pas vraiment le joueur
qui qui
est en train de répondre
peut-être pour ces deux dames c'est deux
et dame F2
pour forcer la nul pas forcer la nulle
tu vois forcer une position qui serait
ça a l'air de
te reprendre reprends
sur F7 pour essayer de liquider le matos
j'essaie de trouver des parce que là je
vois que tous les pièces noires si vous
voulez sont plus actives alors
janof il est en difficulté s'il y a pas
un problème tactique sur ce que je
propose peut-être que ça pourrait tenir
cette histoire plus facilement
mais c'est dur c'est chaud c'est chaud
en tout cas en tout cas il est mal au
temps et une position un peu difficile
je préférais faire venir la dame en C2
avec la même idée
volontairement prendre pour prendre il y
a pas de problème sur E2 mais j'ai même
Dame des quatre qui peut être
intéressant des cinq soumission vous
voyez bien je vous montre juste ce que
je voulais montrer là je me laisse ça et
ça je sais pas si c'est sur un des
rentable mais je mets un peu de
questions même ça même pardon même F6
par exemple
ok stouf à 6 j'avais pas vu que le pion
était assis c'était en l'air au départ
j'avais pas vu non plus bien vu
et là après ça ça il est vrai que j'ai
pas de bon je peux manger 4 mais j'ai
pas de d'échec d'être un échec là et un
dame 5 mine de rien c'est quand même
petite menace que je peux quand même te
faire ici faut faire attention
et j'ai 3 mais bon
qu'on veut faire c'est position c'est
bien que le roi est ouvert mais
bon c'est ça du jeu quand même sauf du
jeu je préfère avoir les Noirs ici quand
même
il est en grande difficulté quand même
alors ça a été joué de tour c'est 7 il
s'est dit je garde un maximum de pièces
et par contre coûte très intéressant
mettre de la pression il se dit il veut
se dégager de la pression adverse en
contre-attaquant René cet exemple là les
mecs quand ils sont en difficulté en
général près d'initiative il existe des
défenses passives en vérité au niveau
amateur c'est très important je pense
d'essayer de mettre le maximum de
pression est-ce que tu aimes là c'est
intéressant
tu prends là je prends là et on joue à
bout
pour EF2 F2
un problème là je peux manger là tu
manges là soit il y a les deux
si j'arrive à le bouffer ça
c'est
compliqué
c'est chaud en tout cas
il va mettre des pots de bains à chaque
coup
et après
une raclée
ça pourrait faire limite un 4-0
ça peut être complètement lancé
c'est très très chaud ça c'est très
solide mais quand même
on vous dit 4-0 mais ça peut être ça
comme deux hein franchement
il y a tout qui peut se passer ici
qu'est-ce qu'on va jouer ici
on a plus de coups 5 secondes chacun
prend des villes j'aimais bien
il va perdre 5 non il a pas voulu faire
ça et c'est avec la finale à la fin
j'étais un Piona qui avance très très
vite si les dames s'échangent le Piona
il est il est il est hyper fort
va gagner parce que
il perdra plus je pense en tout cas
parce qu'à un moment il était pas loin
de perdre là il y a le pion c'est Dame
des 4 C3
[Musique]
allez qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ce fou
il faut jouer un coup là
bien joué je perds
il est parti à fond à 4 à 5 c'est très
très chaud
qui avance jusqu'au bout ça c'est
complètement retourné c'est retourné
complètement le roi qui va revenir
maintenant ici
c'est le pion G6 qui tombe alors c'est
pas encore terminé parce que du coup il
faut manger des pions si les Noirs
arrivent à manger le pion h ça peut être
nul on va tous faire bouffer
faut trouver attention il faut trouver
pref 3
F3 petit coup tempo brisé
et voilà
et après on va chercher le cheval voilà
faut prendre je mange voilà
quoi et on va monter comme ça parfois
mais le roi va revenir vite en fait mais
même sera perdant avec l'option A7 j'ai
déjà joué une finale comme ça souffle et
c'est perdu après
c'est pour ça en fait il aurait dû
on va voir le direct rapidement on va
passer si tu veux à tabac Tabe Eliane 9
du coup
en bonne chance de nul ici
ouais mais c'est pas encore si clair la
tour qui coupe le roi c'est pas mal joué
c'est très fort maintenant je vais
monter
là il faut compter parce que ça ça
tourner
il faut compter
maintenant
on aura plus il y aura peut-être du
temps
on en parlait ces trois et demi trois et
demi 0,5 sans doute
on va aller voir ce qui se passe après
chez pranave il y a une pièce de plus
tout à l'heure c'était ça avait l'air
assez gagnant voilà c'est là c'est sûr
maintenant
tout c'est ça un gros bordel je le
comprends rien alors on débarque là G7
il s'est fait un peu retourné mais
légèrement seulement mais il était
encore plus gagnant tout à l'heure
il a l'air en difficulté quand même
il y a plein de choses en prises donc il
faut quand même faire attention
pour la pièce ça me saoule
je peux vous dire la partie est
totalement relancée regardez les coups
sont un peu bizarres
la Tour Eiffel
j'ai trois H4 encore pour me défendre
le pion surtout je vais essayer
d'échanger le pion B2 si je peux faire
ça
possible pour les blancs
je pouvais pas le faire parce que B4
maintenant toujours pas dame G1 pour
faire un truc
je dois mettre l'adversaire en
difficulté 6 secondes 7 secondes 5
secondes Dame des deux problèmes
essayez de liquider un peu les cadeaux
une pièce d'avance si jamais j'arrive à
mettre un cavalier en H5 ça peut être
pas mal mais bon c'est c'est dur à je
pense
qu'il fait peur
comme la première avec les Blancs si on
fait une bêtise à un moment donc c'est
il y a de la pression quand même
on peut
le dire
[Musique]
un petit peu les dégâts cette partie de
pranave qui qui a fait nul et
une pièce de moins il est pas content
forcément mital mais pranaf s'est battu
comme un lion c'est ça donc du coup ça
fait
5 points et demi à 6 et demi du coup
pour les normes les trois pour les
Indiens qui sont quasiment revenus au
score ils sont menés plus que d'un point
maintenant et il va rester du coup
le dernier set pour départager les
joueurs donc je rappelle aussi qu'une
égalité reste possible et en cas
d'égalité 8 et bon on aura du coup des
départages donc on verra après comment
ça se joue en tout cas il y a plus que
deux points à mettre pour pour les
gnomes et c'est un match qui est qui est
Kevin hyper pas discuter et hyper chaud
donc je vais de ce pas vous mettre du
coup les appareils membres pour la
dernière pour le dernier set
donc je voulais donner en direct si vous
voulez donc c'est les le plus fort
contre le plus fort etc donc ça va être
du coup avec les couleurs ça fait
erikasi blanc
complètement mix là je peux te dire que
ça ça fight et ils ont complètement raté
leur début de match l'équipe
majoritairement indienne puisque il y a
pranaf qui joue dans l'équipe des
nord-ouen
mais là ils sont en train de revenir ils
ont failli mettre 4-0 ils finissent à
trois-1
puis remettre un 3 ça passe et ouais en
plus là tout est possible
tout est possible c'est très chaud et en
plus
[Musique]
tamatabec qui s'est refait un peu qui
qui se remotivent sûrement pour la
dernière partie intéressante il est pas
très en forme non on va avoir le droit à
eljanof et Guizi
c'est ça c'est ça et du coup
[Musique]
tu as quand même plutôt une pièce
surrégaliser après il a un style
tellement peu commun et regisy que des
fois ça passe ou ça casse
dans le deuxième
donc ta batterie
[Musique]
David
du coup
ça va t'abeille blanc je les installe
vous le voyez pas mais je les installe
et ok c'est bon
ce qui s'est passé parce qu'on a vu
qu'il avait un accusé le coup forcément
pièce net de plus entre son collègue
indien et il arrive pas à le finir
ça reste le joueur le plus faible de
l'équipe en vélo donc ça reste toujours
un petit peu frustrant dans ces cas-là
quand vous n'arrivez pas à battre
le joueur que vous avez
au bout de votre fusil il faut le finir
c'est important
et là il y a un petit peu de fatigue sur
ces sessions quand vous enchaînez aussi
vite
4 10 + 2 vous avez pas le droit à
l'erreur
au revoir que des gros matchs à chaque
fois
mais on a vu en tout cas peut-être les
parties les plus disputées là très
clairement depuis que je commente sauf
des machines il y en a eu il y a même
des tailles break que j'ai pu commenter
mais là elle est partie se finissent si
on avait quatre qui se finissaient avec
30 secondes à la pendule c'est super
quoi c'est vraiment sympa c'est clair
je vais envoyer un petit message
à Vanessa
on a eu du bazar au niveau des Carmes
oui
on dirait que tabataba est dans sa
douche
un petit truc
c'est pas mal
rigolo
blague vous savez toujours pareil je
pense qu'il y a quelqu'un qui est parti
dans le stream c'est ça non non
si c'est un truc comme ça tu vois je
m'en fous enfin je sais qu'ils vont
venir mais quand c'est pour le coup là
ce qui se passe là c'est tout à fait
décalé en fait du coup quand on s'est
décalé ben écoute enfin c'était pas déjà
le
la caméra sont pas bonnes du tout chez
les Indiens noirs
et le score est hyper serré
et les neurones malgré leur défaite 3
avec été tellement bon avant qu'il mène
quand même d'un point ils sont en
ballotage favorable mais on peut dire
que
très clairement
chez les simonica a battu tabac Tabe
c'est ça qui les sauve pour le moment si
elle venait à perdre là on serait à
Total égalité resterait trois expliqués
ça va être super tendu
ça serait la logique
c'est
un gros regarde je commence ce que j'ai
un Big Mac
du coup bah tu comprends bien que ça
marche pas tu peux faire des demi-cams
[Musique]
mais si je fais si je fais changement
ici en fait
et ben je pense ça va être remis et ben
je dois tout le refaire à la main en
fait si je le change après donc ça va me
saouler
ah c'est bon ça a été remis cool merci
de l'avoir
très très chaud on s'attendait à un
match équilibré finalement le lead a été
pris par l'équipe
norvégienne et ben comme on le pensait
les Indiens sont complètement revenus en
tout cas
je suis assez content je mentir pas mal
pour l'instant sauf avec ce petit
subduction H3 oui
[Rires]
alors ça c'est un beau j'aime bien
gagner gagner
honnêtement et surtout que si je l'avais
perdu c'est j'aurais été fumé ce que je
suis en H3 tombe tu vois
au final tu sais la fenêtre
un scandale quoi tu vois
me donner l'explication de comment tu
avais détecté
au niveau du curage froid dans la finale
c'est toujours
et du coup du coup il y a donc donc là
elle est partie qui vont démarrer dessus
quelques-uns
un petit peu ce qui se passe
c'est bien calé de toute façon cet
événement là on sait ça démarre 16h30
pile après 19h 19h30 maximum si il y a
il y a un départage c'est vraiment le
maxi de chez Maxi puisque avant
cela ça arrive de temps en temps qu'au
bout de trois matchs ça soit finisse ouf
et ça arrivait deux fois du coup avec un
homme équipe
et à chaque fois c'est les Gotham night
qui mettent deux fois ils ont gagné
trois matchs ils ont fait 303 et cela
trois matchs qu'ils ont gagné ils ont
ils ont gagné 2 sur 3 7 hyper hyper
dangereux en vrai en vrai
donc intéressant donc là est-ce qu'on a
du coup la room 4 qui s'élancée
pas encore chez moi
je l'avais pas un instant j'ai essayé
mais pour autant les gens ont l'air bien
concentré c'est parti c'est parti
ça traditionnel
début Joba le système
alors pourquoi moi je l'ai pas
ok des fois il me mettre la ronde 4 dans
la rue 5
et il me faut une petite des petites
blagues comme ça
que j'aime beaucoup au champ pack vidéo
que je sors sur ma plateforme en ligne
sauf c'est sur ce sujet là
j'adore ce début là je trouve que c'est
un début assez pragmatique et pour ceux
qui aiment les systèmes agressifs c'est
bien c'est pas une théorie trop
importante c'est pas tout le temps
agressif parce que des fois il y a des
positions plus calme et en règle
générale c'est agressif je pensais que
c'était plutôt cavalier aux deux
qu'est-ce qui se passe sur cavalier 4 on
donne
on va défendre avec dames
mais qu'est-ce quelles sont les
documents ce qui veut jouer
à trois et te dire bonjour
[Musique]
c'est lui qui le joue je me dis je vais
j'ai envie de lui faire confiance quoi
si vous voulez
ça donne envie d'aller voir d'aller
bouffer
je sais pas trop
c'est sympa sympatoche j'allais chercher
ça
qu'est-ce qu'on a en compensation dire
qu'est-ce qu'on oublie
peut-être qu'il bluff complet non je
pense pas quand même dans une partie de
top de Top 16 la première ronde est
jouée avec Clovis Vernet
et il avait fait une partie dégueu il
était très fatigué il venait d'un
tournoi etc je pense qu'il était cramé
ah du coup on ne saura pas stuff n'a pas
été pris le pion donné aljanaf a préféré
jouer assez modeste et va jouer une
partie
peut-être un peu plus difficile mais
avec des fous de couleur opposés donc
annulant pour jouer Dame des trois C4
peut-être
facile à côté
côté blanc maintenant et souffrir est-ce
qu'on peut voir ce qui se passait sur
cahier prend ces trois qu'est-ce qu'on a
raté peut-être rien il y a peut-être
juste des compensations ça va les
prendre ces trois B prend ses trois faut
prendre ces trois juste tourbé 1
c'est pas transparent
petit rock je pense se ferme
c'était une préparation clairement
il sait surtout que le mec est bien
préparé
donc
là qui peut arriver je m'attendais trois
C4 mais ça a pas été joué
du coup ok est-ce qu'on fait un petit
tour
Kevin là ici c'est un match important
donc là on a tabacabay avec les Blancs
contre David hawel donc ça c'est
peut-être maintenant un coup si la vidéo
elle ne voit pas c'est
ultra théorique et
version très solide pour David Owell
très solide et bon je sais pas on verra
ce qui se passe mais quand même aussi
des chances de de faire nul aussi exact
et du coup troisième partie ce serait du
coup pranave contre
Arica et c'est une position assez
bizarre alors on va voir un peu ce qui
s'est passé sicilienne dragon hyper
accéléré avec Dame Descartes qui est un
bon choix
je crois pas que ce soit nouveau T mais
bon c'est un des coups je te dis moi je
connais pas en fait pour moi ça me dit
quelque chose mais de toute façon comme
tu dis sauf je suis bien d'accord c'est
c'est rare
je sais pas comment tu le veux
au lieu de
obligé de jouer tout de suite il y a
peut-être des cinq après tu me diras
donc E5
qui existe donc je suis pas sûr de
vouloir vraiment je sais 4
même V4 là il donne tout petit tu peux
jouer rock parce que après tu feras des
bateaux d'un match 4 fois 6 en deux
ouais c'est ça bon ça existe aussi c'est
pas
aujourd'hui
c'est quand même plutôt bien pour les
noirs a priori ce que je vois par
rapport à l'ordinateur
de venir en Détroit
attaque le pion
et rock ça fait peur quand même pour les
noirs
est une bonne décision quand même pour
prendre F6 dans de bonnes conditions
pas trop m'attache
si souvent
et c'est une partie qui se joue il y a
un pion de plus pour les Noirs mais
avant je prends pour les blancs et plein
de cases noires assez faible donc bon en
fait voilà il joue vite et en pratique
c'est pas simple du tout pour le noir ça
ça peut vite arriver
en fait objectivement c'est sans doute
pas terrible c'est la jauge qui nous le
dit mais
il nous confirme en tout cas mais ça
m'aide la pression comme nous disent
tous et pranave joue très vite donc vous
pouvez tilter avec les Blancs et
surestimer un petit peu la position
blanche du fait que l'adversaire joue
très très vite quoi
et du coup la dernière partie c'est la
partie du coup de
celle-ci contre mital
et donc on a une position c'est une
sorte de
c'est une Anglaise extension un petit
peu en retti
quand même parce qu'on voit qu'on est
complètement troué à l'endroit et qu'on
a une idée même c'est H6 noir qui un
jour trop rare
ce cette là l'aile où on a voulu avancer
il y a la case de trois faibles la case
H4 il y aura foudé cette fosse 6
on a vraiment complètement raté mais en
plus on a un pion de moins on sait même
pas pourquoi
elle a les passes à côté bon alors de
toute façon elle a fait son travail
elle a battu tabac Tabeille
pour rien non mais là c'est du non
cosmos là notre notre ami je sais pas ce
qu'elle a voulu faire souffre mais non
je ne comprends pas tabataba ici voit la
partie va se dire mais
pas très content mais bon après on sait
tous que une partie on peut la
c'est pas une partie très très brillante
en tout cas il ramène les deux équipes à
égalité vraisemblablement sauf gros
retournement ça paraît étonnant et ça va
jouer sur les trois parties
blanc contre elianov donc c'est quand
même plutôt l'expérience quand même le
joueur qui a eu 27 60 dans sa carrière
même peut-être plus que ça date 70 il a
eu 4 il y a 9 top 10 mondial
les deux pièces là il faut que je bouge
madame c'est pas trop trop le choix je
crois voilà c'est la seule case en 8 à
part des 7
comment
de la dame et on peut imaginer un coup
du style tu vois en fubou c'est même pas
trop où on met ce fou trois je pense
même à être envisageable
ce pion si je le mange après je mets mon
four en baissant
donc il a mangé le pion en C3
donc ça donne un pion de plus au noir
mais bon ça pion là sont un petit peu
doublés donc c'est pas très révélateur
par contre celui-là est en prise aussi
ouais c'est ça mais maintenant du coup
qu'est-ce que je fais 3 C4 tant pis je
craque à 4 et on y va c'est 4 et les
placements des pièces noires c'est quand
même pas si simple
surprise qu'elle va les prendre il y a
du cavalier des six pour chatte qui peut
arriver qui est un peu désagréable donc
placement de pièces quand même non c'est
pas simple
il y a eu ta mort c'est un peu bizarre
c'est bizarre mais je mange là
bkus même peut-être même sur ça
peut-être même alors je sais pas mais je
pense à cavalier B2 pour venir en C4 et
essayer de bloquer comme ça avec le fou
pardon on met 5 c'est un peut-être un
petit peu de trop de
en tout cas on aime bien l'initiative
des blancs les pièces sont plus jolies
voilà la dernière arrivée en B4
hyper intéressant en tout cas cette
pause là c'est matériel entre contre
l'initiative la colonne B et les pièces
qui sont bizarrement placés quand même
il faut le dire
et alors que nous j'ai un beau cavalier
là qui quand même contre pas mal de
cases qui fait des choses un pion qui
peut être passer très fort qui empêche
les noirs de prendre le contrôle de la
colonne le tourbillon qui peut arriver
et ce cavalier en A4 c'est un petit peu
une pièce tu vois
après c'est simple cavalier il bouge
plus hein
sans limite j'ai envie de te dire je
fais c'est 5 je fais ça je fais ça et je
mange quoi
[Musique]
tu bouges tu bouges
désagréable quand même pour pour les
Noirs
donc si ça fait un zéro que Chelsea
Monica perd contre mital ce qui est et
ben il faut que
moi un petit peu là tabac Tabeille
après faut voir ouais ouais
c'est quand même belle tête de nul et du
coup faudra vraiment que
que
pranave gagne avec les Blancs et ça
c'est quand même possible tu vois la
position noire a quand même bizarre déjà
ça c'est déjà dégradé
par rapport à tout à l'heure et mais si
ça se passe comme on prédit
et ben on arrive en départage Kevin
c'est possible donc on va voir c'est en
tout cas c'est chaud c'est intéressant
cette partie parce que j'aime pas
j'aime bien aussi la partie dérigazie
qui est très intéressante
et d'ailleurs il y a eu du C5
il a compris que le cavalier était était
perdu ici donc il a été forcé vraiment
de de faire cavaler les bêtises alors la
prise ici était peut-être pas possible à
cause de cavalier prend qui vraiment la
case la case des 6 plus la protection
cavalier A4 par transparence et rendu
difficile
complètement mais là il y a quand même
une belle initiative côté blanc avec un
colonne vert et l'entrée en B7
éventuellement et le pion qui peuvent
tomber et puis et puis ce pion qui est
vraiment une épine dans la position des
noirs
tour c'est un exercice donc son cavalier
7 tu joues comment
est-ce que tu veux jouer
il y a c'est ce qui intéresse
ça se regarde avec Dame prend à 6
ouais
il les voit des cases les petits trous
les gars il y a ça en l'air il y a ça là
très difficile à cette position en tout
cas
franchement quelle créativité encore
dans cette partie qui donne le pion C3
qui donne tous les pions tout ça pour
pour jouer actif
j'aime beaucoup ce qui s'est aggasi
encore
me laisser peut-être l'option de faire
un dame B oui tout occupé aussi la
colonne B est-ce qu'on peut pas dire
sauf que là
Erika easy va gagner et on pourrait
peut-être aller vers une autre partie
envoyé alors peut-être juste pour venir
un petit peu à la partie on s'est arrêté
à E6 C4 d'un point avec son s'arrêter là
qu'il est deux les cavalu le 5 de jouer
qui apparemment est une gaffe mais bon
qui est très difficile à imaginer cette
position
pour essayer de vite échanger d'âme et
là il y a une belle séquence je trouve
des Noirs Foussais 5 et G5 et là c'est
intéressant d'attaquer le roi dans ce
type de position qui attaquent la dame
et aussi en plus défend H7 tu vois donc
intéressant comme idée et dame j'ai
froid si le pion G5 avait été pris il y
avait des idées sur casse blanche
donc qui peut arriver à ce qu'on peut
imaginer un petit défi peut-être Kevin
pour empêcher un cavalier 5 un pêcher
les tours 5
l'idée
en fait il y a eu F6 un peu de la même
idée qui empêche ça
l'avantage c'est que ça tient G5 mais
j'étais pas sûr
les joueurs c'est pareil c'est une
position tellement aiguë vous le voyez
atypique du coup prendre les bonnes
décisions dans ce dans ce genre de
position c'est extrêmement difficile de
d'avoir des scores parfaits ce qu'on
cherche voilà avoir une cohérence
générale et l'urgence de la position
maintenant ça va être la valorisation du
foot C8 et pas prendre l'eau au niveau
du roi c'est pour ça que Arica a décidé
d'attaquer avec ses pions l'ail roi des
blancs c'est plutôt bien inspiré
quelque part
mais je pensais mais un truc toi que moi
des fois j'arrive pas à m'empêcher à je
découpe au point débile
et je garde mais ok mais la dame défend
déjà le fou en fait mon idée c'est que
je voulais attaquer le fou mais du coup
tu m'as contrées
sortir le Phocéen le fou c'est 5 est
joli on vient les changer ça fait sens
je peux ramener le tour ici et j'ai
aussi récupéré la case des cartes pour
cavalier que je n'avais pas depuis que
tu avais le four en ces cinq j'avais de
la case vous voyez donc c'est c'est un
coup qui est assez cool on va échanger
ici si je peux
exactement
quelle est la priorité dans la position
et là c'était sorti la poussière ça se
ça se ressent d'ailleurs et on arrive à
trouver les coudes et des champions des
fois Magnus et le spécialiste des coups
simples
et du coup des fois on voit que c'est
parti sont vraiment limpides hyper bien
construite un roi F7 un Rica et 7 cacher
son roi c'est plus dur à jouer de son
côté
je réponds à B6 moi sauf pour essayer de
faire fouter cette toujours par rapport
à l'urgence de la position ou D6 vous
décède B6 ou B7 ça veut dire normalement
je suis désolé
bonsoir à tous ceux qui arrivent salut à
toi cher
donc fousser 5 il va y avoir dames et 5
ok 2 il veut revenir cavalier 4 kd6 le
joueur avec le cavalier regarde avec
attention les belles cases
il y a kb3 aussi mais c'est vraiment la
case E4 pour D6 qu'on veut donc
qu'est-ce qu'on joue F5 avec les Noirs
j'ai pas trop envie de jouer F5 mais
qu'est-ce que je peux faire sur cad2 on
va être dur la position elle a joué F5
prise de décision donc là peut-être
cavalier 3
en grande difficulté
je pense que c'est pour ça
la caméra déconnecte et puis là on voit
cavalier F3 qu'est-ce qu'on joue je sais
pas
vous savez que là on va voir si l'équipe
des joueurs indiens mais
deux points et demi on ira au match de
partage
on a eu le petit haschis cavalier E5 va
sans doute être joué tout radin
peut-être après on va commencer à aller
chercher le roi parti très très
importante qu'on voit ici il va très
important qui est très disputé
tout et n'importe quoi il y a trois
résultats possibles
en pratique c'est tellement facile à
jouer pour les blancs
harika de laisser la prise 7
bien plié
je pense qu'on est plié ici tout court
ailleurs
tu vois tu as raison
a été récupéré
si on fait C7 on peut le tenir un petit
moment mais pas longtemps il y aurait
peut-être même C7
ah oui
cavaliers C6 dans le même esprit un
esprit tactique aussi
et ok donc le pion va être perdu et là
qui peut
jamais la cadence est traître
beaucoup de temps pour les joueurs
compliqué du coup c'est pas clair
c'est une finale il s'est passé quoi là
il y a eu un pion qui était donné par
tabataba
dans cette partie les Noirs vont gagner
oh là là c'est plus du tout le même
match vous avez dit
trois B3 celui de C3 sur moi
il y a une répétition qui a qui est qui
a été faite mais tu as peut-être la
justice 5 ou activer un petit peu des
pièces
centraliser le roi peut-être mais il y a
toujours trois
du coup
l'histoire c'est 3 B3
qui doit être bon peut-être faut
calculer bien mais cette position
donc tout se joue là ça fait
[Musique]
on a le score qui a été fait et on voit
du coup à 8 points pour
pas rattraper là
il reste plus que cette partie c'est
aryka contre prana on va les voir
on va aller voir et là du coup il y a eu
un petit forge royale attends on va voir
ce qui s'est passé on a le match le
résultat qui sont ici les gars on voit 9
7 pour les les gnoms oui c'est ça le pic
effectivement
David awell a gagné et à plomber
l'équipe
effectivement
la totale d'un point 8 très joli point
tactique vous voyez avec l'histoire de
cavaliers pronostic triple fourchette
belle partie entrepreneur et harica mais
victoire et victoire d'ailleurs de
l'équipe de prana voilà au revoir et
davidoël hyper content de lui et ouais
ça cette victoire et ben c'est du coup
synonyme de de qualification pour les
cartes de finale donc c'est bien sûr
hyper bien ils ont fait le job ils sont
qualifiés c'était chaud c'était chaud et
là c'est juste gagnant donc du coup
hyper cool pour les les non oui non ce
qui se qualifie pour les quarts de
finale et du coup les les Indiens donc
l'équipe d'irégasi et ben c'est mort un
petit peu les doigts cette victoire tu
vois Tabata Bay qui qui
[Musique]
a perdu contre Chelsea Monica et qui du
coup
si la partie avait été le score avait
été inversé il y aurait 8 8 tu vois
après c'est pas bien sur lui qui parle
de l'équipe mais tu vois que ça se voit
pas grand chose en tout cas ce match
et du coup les joueurs qui quittent qui
quittent tout ça donc on va revenir sur
une journée hyper difficile il fait un
sur quatre joueurs à quasiment 200700
touffe la totale quoi pour lui yes
dur dur et je croyais qu'on allait avoir
un match de partage et me craquer dans
le compte tellement je croyais au match
de départage et finalement c'est 9 7 on
était pas loin on était pas loin
donc du coup il y a pas de matchs de
partage donc on a une calife pour
l'équipe de norwenn et du coup bah nous
on va vous laisser là pour aujourd'hui
il y a un mec vous allez pouvoir
[Musique]
donc oui en ce qui me concerne moi je
vais passer stream je stream ce soir si
vous voulez mais d'ici une heure et
demie deux heures à peu près ce soir je
stream et donc sur ma chaîne je vais
faire un petit un petit
n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre et donc
allez voir ce que ce soir si ça vous
intéresse du faire un petit coucou
on est en stream régulièrement moins peu
moins ces derniers temps mais en tout
cas tout fait et là ce soir donc allez
lui faire un petit coucou ça ça aide
toujours si vous pouvez me faire un
petit saut
moi je peux pas le faire
voilà les deux
voilà le lien de ma chaîne je serai en
ligne d'ici une heure et demie deux
heures à peu près donc voilà où on se
retrouvera pour d'autres événements
chascom tout au long de la saison voilà
on vous tient au courant sur sur les sur
les réseaux et autres en tout cas
c'était bien plaisant sauf de suivre
tout ça tranquillement on a bien bien
rigolé c'était intense comme match en
plus donc pour le attaque et à commenter
c'est c'est vraiment très agréable quand
c'est comme ça
donc du coup on verra un petit peu la
semaine prochaine ce que nous avons
comme comme match et puis bon on espère
du coup vous revoir nombreux lors de nos
événements et donc on vous remercie en
tout cas pour votre fidélité tout ça et
du coup du coup voilà donc bonne soirée
à tous bonne soirée à toi Kevin et merci
de m'avoir accompagné
salut salut à bientôt